bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
pour la suite de ce championnat du monde
d'échecs 2016 entre donc le tenant du
titre magnus carsen 26 ans le norvégien
face à horus un sergueï kaliakine 26 ans
aussi et donc coup de tonnerre coup de
tonnerre dans la 8e puisque donc
regarder le score ici après ici huit
partis et bien servi et kara qui ne mène
d'un point une belle victoire qui il a
pu profiter d'une deuxième erreur de
carsen après avoir raté peut-être un
avantage suite à une première erreur
personne qui semblait un peu un peu un
peu fatigué il fait il fait des erreurs
deux erreurs
bon des erreurs on peut filmer mais ça a
suffi pour crack in pour après avoir un
peu souffert dans la première partie du
match mais en ayant tenu et bien de
marquer finalement le point inattendu
qui pourrait le propulser et devenir le
17e champion du monde d'échecs après
donc une série 1 de champion qui remonte
à steinitz en 1886 steinitz hélas caire
ensuite à prix lasker capablanca aller
qui ne peuvent ensuite on a eu droit
bobigny que tu as le smi ce loft
petrossian spassky fischer karpov
kasparov kramnik anand l'indien
extraordinaire en inde qui donc a laissé
son titre ou à l'extraordinaire aussi
maintenu ce qu'arsène qui quand même
fait la loi
depuis maintenant pas mal de temps déjà
depuis plusieurs années il tient le
thrones le trône des grands champions du
monde de l'histoire est là pour la
première fois il est donc en difficulté
en difficulté en match il ne reste que
quatre parties à carson pour essayer de
revenir
est-ce qu'il va réussir un come back
maintenant peut-être qu'on en a vu par
exemple dans le match kasparov et karpov
de 1987
rappelez-vous 6 ou si vous l'avez
et pas vécu bien regarder ce match
extraordinaire ou kasparov a réussi à
gagner la dernière partie une partie
vraiment extrêmement tendue ils étaient
menés d'un point il restait qu'une
partie là il reste quatre parties à
carson c'est quand même mieux mais c'est
quand même très dur parce qu'il aura que
deux fois les blancs pour essayer de
revenir dans ce match donc c'est la
neuvième quart yakine donc pièce blanche
face à magnus carsen le tenant du titre
pièce noah qui est donc mené d'un point
comment car ce n va a négocié cette
partie on va voir déjà ce que je vous
parlais kino premier coup et bien c'est
parti avec eux quatre
est-ce qu'on va encore avoir droit à une
rue lopez et bien on va voir ça tout de
suite avec les coups suivants e5
pour l'instant on prend la route de la
rue lopez carril f3 cavaliers c6 et oui
ça ressemble beaucoup et maintenant boom
sayo nier la fameuse ouverture oui lopez
donc henry lopez décès ghoul a considéré
comme le père de la théorie avec son
premier le premier grand livre théorique
qui recense les l'ensemble on peut dire
des ouvertures pratique à l'époque un du
jeu d'échecs dont l'invention de cette
fameuse rue lopez ou partie espagnole de
ce livre donc le livre de l'invention
libéral et art du jeu d'échecs de rue
lopez sigouin 1561 donc à 500 ans de
distance et bien on le voit toujours
voit toujours cette ouverture dans les
championnats du monde ce qui montre la
profondeur et d' analyse de du moins
espagnol très grands joueurs donc de son
temps considéré comme le meilleur du
monde de son temps bien entendu fourbe
et 5 à 6 x 4 4e 6 voilà la même
ouverture qu'on a déjà vu petit rock
laprise attention ici en 4 1 6 6 pour
les blancs
ici les noirs prennent le 4 c'est pas
très grave on joue toujours eu un goût
on peut même jouer des cas tout de suite
il y aura un clouage à la fin ce qui
fait que les blancs récupère avec une
ouverture du jeu ça se joue ça s'appelle
l'espagnol ouverte mais voilà il faut
c'est les noirs qui choisissent donc ils
choisissent bessalah prennent pas un
quatrième doublé 5 four b3 et maintenant
s'ils prennent un cadre c'est encore
pareil il ya une aura tôt ou même des
quatre tout de suite considéré sans
doute quant au mieux comme meilleur avec
le fameux clouage sur la colonne neuf
donc les noirs ne prennent pas il
choisit de ne pas rentrer ces drames qui
est un peu dangereuse fou csn contre
wall e maximale sur la caisse des quatre
à quatre voilà donc ici et donc on a un
peu varié des parties précédentes avec
fous ces 5 à 4 c'est une autre idée à
prendre apprend attention il ya
vis-à-vis tout retour donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait on pourrait jouer faux
bessette mais les noirs veulent
peut-être là encore laissé là leur fou
parce qu'on pourrait le développer de
l'autre côté et on garde un maximum de
souplesse
regardez ce pion des il attend aussi il
a attendu il attend toujours de savoir
s'il va jouer un des six ou pourquoi pas
en d5 avec on l'a déjà vu dans une
partie précédente de ce championnat du
monde un quasi gambie marshall
alors là aussi je vous invite à vous
renseigner sur ce fabuleux livre réédité
1-2 capablanca 1920 juste avant son
match contre l'ask aires où ils avaient
analysé le premier gambie marshall face
à marshall voilà ces marchés elles
avaient préparé ce hobby face à
capablanca ça fait partie des idées de
cette ouverture donc il faut les
connaître parce que tout et ses idées
peuvent revenir à tout moment
donc si tours v8 pour les noirs et la c3
ces trois intéressant c3 et la gambie
marche elle pourrait se faire peut-être
mais on a déjà je vous le fou alors je
pense que les noirs auraient perdu un
temps puis le court le général à 4 est
considéré comme un anti gambie en
général c'est considéré comme empêchant
le gambit pour des raisons troisième
positionnelle donc c'est sans doute pas
l'idée des noirs ici des six voix la
plus calme tranquille des six on protège
à noter qu'on a sorti le fou au delà de
la ligne de la ligne 2 pions donc il est
plus actif sur cette grande diagonale
quant au 7 mai mais en cas de clouage
pas refouler 5
on pourra pas revenir des clous et ce
qui peut poser des soucis des six est un
bon coup bien sûr des quatre là on
attaque tout de suite le fou quoi pas le
foot revenir obligé d'emmener en b 6 ou
le retenir à 7 mai à sept voiliers après
prise prise bas le fouet est attaqué par
la tour ce qui pose un problème aux
cavaliers là qui peut se faire attaquer
par des 5 et 6 bouge évidemment le fou
est perdu donc il vaut mieux pas évités
il faut éviter comme ça de mettre des
pièces sur des colonnes potentiellement
ouverts tout on peut ouvrir voilà parce
qu'ils pourraient ça peut poser des
problèmes donc foulée 6 est évidemment
un bon coup ce qui bouge un peu l'action
de la tour mais c'est pas très grave les
noirs estime que ce fou ils n'ont et
puissant ce qui est vrai voilà c'est
très importantes se foutrait actifs
attention les blancs sont aussi
attaquées en 4 ici et on n'a pas le
temps de jouer h3 pour que le fou
viennent
ne viennent pas en danger car s'ils se
fout bien vient au g4 indirectement sac
loubet sur le cavalier ça c'est un
premier point mais ça ça crée une
pression sur des cartes toutes les
pièces noires attaques des 4 et le
cahier ne protège plus vraiment
puisqu'il attaqué par le fou c'est un
peu l'idée on va voir ça à prendre
apprend cavaliers à trois attaques le
pion b5
mais noah ont plein menaces peuvent
jouer fou g4 on peut prendre en et 4
plein de trucs donc les noirs se disent
bien tant pis vas-y prend le le pion aux
rockets pas mal intéressant alors la
carrière qui n'a plein de coups
possibles comme on peut envisager jouer
ou g5 mais dans ce cas-là h6 en cas de
repli de fous j'ai 5 lf ou sans doute
revient en g3 ou alors ça il y aurait
sacrifice des blancs mais c'est quand
même tendu et 6 revient j'ai trois ans
après dans ce cas là il ya le pion aux
quatre ans prises on pourrait même
prendre des quatre avants prises et puis
ensuite puis on comprend qu calibre 4 et
on a pris un gros pion central donc
ici les blancs pourrait jouer ça mais il
joue il préfère ça ça pose un problème
puisque dont quelques uns quatre grands
prix il préfère prendre le pion b5 voilà
j'aurais pu aussi aussi tenté le coup
tout re 1
mais tous roumains protège ici mais ça
empêche pas fou g4 qui cloue et qui pose
un problème sur des 4 et 6e puis on
prend les noirs sont tranquilles on
reprend du cavalier avec un cavalier
cloud ici c'est une catastrophe pour les
blancs et en plus ça libère la diagonale
dessous et oui ce fou devient
extrêmement actif dès que le pion des
quatre saute donc là les blancs on
préfère prendre mais c'est néanmoins
voilà j'ai pris un pion et je vais
rentrer dans quelque chose de tendue
vers les quarts seignoux très actif fou
j'ai quatre superbes clouage est donc là
encore une fois pression sur des quatre
contre un pion on a quand même donné un
pion mais vous allez voir un lit des
fous ces deux les blancs attention
enlève une pièce ils ont combattants
sion et un tour là donc voilà il enlève
une pièce de cette colonne
potentiellement très dangereuse le
cavaly potentiellement emprise le fou
derrière aussi hier d'exfo bouge bas si
on si on casse en d4
ici dès que ce fou prend f2 parent avec
échec le cavaly temps prises derrière
peut-être le fou aussi emprise donc on
l'enlève ici et en même temps on protège
4 voilà un coup à la fois défensif
j'enlève une pièce potentiellement l'air
pour protéger le pion attaquer donc là
les noirs sont avec un pion de moins
mais une grosse initiative calculez bien
sûr il est pas rentrer là dedans par
hasard regarder la suite puis on prend
des quatre cavaliers prend très bon coup
bien entendu je prends du cavalier
puisque je garde le pian c3 j'empêche
lecavalier 6 devenir en b4 j'empêche
aussi et bien en reprenant du pied
j'aurais pu mais en reprenant du pur je
laisse le cas vaillant prise donc je
laisse les noirs pouvoir tenter les
choses au centre des choses compliquées
qu'on va pas avoir ce serait trop long
mais voilà quel pays prendrait quatre
c'est simplement une cuite ivement
comprend le coup j'enlève le cavalier de
de la potentielle prise de la tour b 8
dès que ce four à jouer un jour c'est
fini a plus cette histoire là et je
reprends au centre et maintenant
simplement les noirs prennent en d4 et
après prise bah oui pour l'un c'est que
les blancs peuvent pas à la fois à
protéger des 4es f300 doubler les pions
voilà c'est à dire que les noirs ont
doublé les pieds au stade y prennent en
f3 si je prends la dame lennon en gagner
c'est à dire qu'enfin gagner ils ont
pris près le pion des quatre ils ont
simplifié la position ils ont des pions
ici lié contre ont pu isoler en b2 qui
n'est pas passée puisque ton c7 est là
et donc un terme de structure va c'est
un peu mieux pour les noirs mais bon les
blancs la paire de fou mais sans doute
les noms ont déjà égalisé
si la dame prend donc les blancs pour
garder un petit avantage prennent du
plomb g voilà pour garder un petit
avantage de près du plancher et donc ils
ont toujours en point de plus mais mais
mais évidemment à tout ça c'est pas bon
c'est à dire que le roi blanc à des
rites comme peu en l'air donc les blancs
un pion de plus la paire de fou notre
premier critère ou la foux pour les
pères de fou peut s'exprimer quand même
assez vite on peut créer des ruptures on
peut ouvrir etc
mais mais mais un roi faible avec des
pions doublé des pions isolé bon voilà
c'est la compensation noa qu'elle a 5
très bons coups kailash 5 ou actif deux
idées on peut venir en h4 avec la dame
petite pression ici sur les droits on
peut aussi envisager pourquoi pas plus
tard f5
si les blancs prennent à l'horizon des
pions triplé voilà c'est jamais très
agréable les dunes triplé ils peuvent
pas céder ils sont vraiment très très
faible et 3,5 aussi permettrait une tour
devenir un f6 et de coulisses et plus
tard son âge 6 ou jessie si les bleus
prennent pas en 25
voilà ce genre d'idées qui pourrait
survivre surgir peut-être pas tout de
suite parce que c'est fou la vie non
sont quand même très actif aussi
mais voilà qu'avec 5 c'est un bon coup
sûr tout ça libère la dame et ça peut me
laisser plus tard aussi devenu un f4 la
dame peut venir un f6 aussi et on va
jouer quel f4 pour
contrer ce fou ici puis aussi contrôler
les cases proche du roi blanc crée des
menaces wash voilà ça explique le coup
de karuïa keane faut pas laisser le roi
c'est comme ça sur une colonne où il
peut subir un échec aux achats en même
temps cette tour tôt ou tard pourra
venir en juin pour avoir du jeu mais
aussi on s'enlève à anjouan ration de
cette fameuse grande diagonale ici voyez
donc c'est un coup très important rachat
ou prophylactiques on appelle ça c'est
nîmes jovovich qui avait un peu monté
cette technique
y a pas de menace directe mais voilà on
anticipe les menaces ultérieure en place
au mieux ces pièces d'un même si ce mois
là on l'avait dit c'est une idée non
seulement on vise la case f4 pour le
cavalier pour pourquoi pas bon on vise
aussi le pion f3 donc du coup l adam
peut pas aller n'importe où puisque le
pion étant prises et en même temps aussi
attention la tacc le pion des quatre
donc les blancs sont obligés de jouer un
coup de défense voilà très bien phu
trois coups de développement écoute
défense a noté que ce coup bien s'ils
défendent et 4 par contre il s b 2 un
petit peu emprise et il ya la tourbe et
8 qui veillent donc attention dès que
c'est que ça ça peut jouer et du jeu
donc arsène en profite pour justement
activé au maximum le jeu doom c5
voilà très bons très bons coups pression
sur des 4 si les blancs jouent des 5 et
bien les noirs ont qui peut gagner
puisqu'ils ont ici récupérer les quatre
centrales e5 des quatre ça les arrange
lecavalier pourrait venir sauter en f4
c'est une possibilité
ils peuvent aussi simplement à qui
viennent tour à 8
elle pourrait venir en cinq sets tour 1
pourquoi pas pour essayer de s'activer
sur la société angèle un bon c'est pas
immédiat enfin voila mais en tout cas il
aurait un peu forcé les blancs a alors
donné du jeu attention sur des cinq
aussi tout simplement il ya aussi le
pian médoc et emprise
donc c'est quand même chaud faut
calculer tout ça donc car yakine choisi
une autre solution qui est une très
bonne idée voilà de karuïa guînes pour
contrer ce coup ces cinq actifs
si on prend ces cinq c'est possible
aussi dans ce cas là puis on prend ces
cinq ans pour regarder rapidement car
car c'est avait sans doute prévu ici de
reprendre tout simplement du pion des ou
du fou
nous faut aussi ça a l'air pas mal loin
fo prend c'est le rebond tout simplement
fou prend c'est celle qu d'attention
voilà tout simplement pression maximale
ici sur sur le pion sur le pion b avec
l'opposition pour les noirs et un jeu
équilibré
voilà donc sur ces 5 carats king jouet
un coup intéressant e55 avantages et
inconvénients avantages d'abord c'est un
très bon coup puisque ça attaque bien
sûr la dame bon ça oblige les noirs je
vous découvre ses s'est jamais mauvais
mais en même temps ça attaque la base
ici des six la base du pion c5
donc en cas de prise beaumont reprend
ses 5 et attention on aurait dans ce cas
là deux pions passées est liée il
faudrait encore avancé le pion b en mai
4 pour ce soit vraiment efficace
et attention des pions passé lié comme
ça avec la paire de fou c'est vraiment
pas une bonne idée
donc faut surtout pas prendre avec les
noirs mais en ce cas là les blancs
comprendront des six avec un pion c5 qui
va être obligé de s'échanger le
désavantage évidemment jour le 5 c'est
que en éliminant les pions là on isole
encore plus ses pions la f3 à f2 ne
peuvent plus et bien ceux reliés aux
points centraux
donc c'est des pions et non seulement
doubler mais isolé tout autant que le
pion rage de dents que ça fait ça fait
bien encore plus le roi noir mais
surtout les chaînes de pions donc en
termes de structure c'est bon pour pour
qu'arsène mais attention en termes
d'activité des fous c'est bon pour
carnitine puisqu'on attaque h7
on a on a libéré en a libéré le 7
grandes diagonales la voilà donc
attention c'est un coup donc le 5 à
double tranchant extrêmement actif et
très bon dans la en termes de structure
de pions pour casser cette mini mini
chaîne noirs ici donc là ici car c'est
donc ne prend pas puisqu'on viennent
très présentes puis on pensait 5 2 pions
parce qu'elle y est c'est pas bon
simplement il joue dames 6 voilà on a
tenté maintenant attention ils menacent
de prendre des 4,5 toutes les menaces
sont bonnes à noter aussi qu'en 1,6 peut
venir h3 et faire pression un peu sur le
roi ici attaque toujours f3 mais une
petite oeil sur ht / g 2 / h 2e après
des échanges de pian le fou pour avenir
en c'est cette attaque et h2 aussi
attention la dame ici à double tranchant
pression sur le centre petit oeil sur
les lois dangereuses
puis on prend des six voilà on élimine
la base déjà pour commencer
très bon coup de car c'est ni si ces
quatre excellents superbe
moi j'adore ce coup très positionnait
l'on reprend pas tout de suite en d6 on
n'est pas pressé et ont créé une
position de stress c'est à dire que ce
pion avancé ici et bien à un oeil bien
sûr sûr avec la dame sur la case d3
potentiellement la tout aussi surveiller
encore le fou ici mais potentiellement
avec la tour sur la case d3 case b3 qui
empêcherait définitivement le plan b 2
d'avancé donc ce pion serait arriérés
sous la menace de rupture avancée
décisive à tomber ce serait une position
très avantageuse pour les noirs donc la
cara qui ne laisse pas faire
immédiatement il a compris il faut
surtout pas rentrer là dedans donc b3
voilà il élimine il élimine son pion b
contre le pion c4 et ça c'est bon pour
le noir parce que ça élimine un pion pas
s'éloigner potentiel il a choisi de ne
pas prendre en d4 avec son pion il
choisit de pas de pas laisser ça à parce
qu'avec la paire de fou s'il ya des
pions des deux côtés avec notamment des
pions qui peut venir passer à l on peut
à la fois attaquer le roi tout en
protégeant l'avancée du pion avec des
fous très actif père de fouet aux
intentions très dangereux en finale très
puissant donc on élimine sas y en a
moins de moins d'activité sur les deux
ailes c'est la rolls une seule elle avec
des pions plus facile de contenir la
paire de fou que dans le cas contraire
c'est prend b3
juste à temps voilà donc est donc ici
s'il peut obliger de prendre priori les
noix
il aurait pu jouer aussi peut-être voilà
un coup comme tous rêvent dé 8 était
jouable
c'était bien parce que le fou peut pas à
les protéger des 6 1 mais on peut pas
protéger avec des buts avait l'air bien
mon jeu
une préférence pour ce coup mais c'est
pas pas forcément le meilleur
on carsen préfère prendre tout
simplement c'est pas plus mal et après
fou prend b3 attention regardez comme ce
fou et actif la dermite attaquer
derrière le pion à vii le roi donc car
c'est maintenant prend pas de problème
donc toujours un pion de moins pour les
noirs mais est ce vraiment un pur -
regardez le pion de plus il est là quoi
donc c'est un pion de doubler et sur des
pions isolé à la fois isolé doublé on
peut pas considérer qu'il ya vraiment un
pionnier pour les noirs c'est pas vrai
c'est un faux pinot - même si bon ici
voilà assez solides pour protéger le roi
les pions doublé tant qu on les bouge
pas ça contre beaucoup de cases est
quand même bon on peut pas dire que
c'est plaisant à voir ça côté droit la
finale ne serait pas vraiment difficile
à défendre pour les noirs dit fier de
savoir qui al'avantage ici il ya un
équilibre dynamique donne plus sauf pour
les blancs attention le plein des quatre
quand même centrale passé mais le roi un
blanc est très faible
donc il faut quand même faire attention
03/06 très bons coups clouage ici sur la
sur la 6e du collège latéral le fonds
doit pas bouger il ya la dame et
maintenant voilà tous restés huit la
seule pièce qui ne jouait pas encore on
l'activé y est très important quand on
voit encore qu'on a des pièces qui ne
joue pas donc paraître côté blanc
réfléchissez deux minutes regardez là
qu'elle ne joue pas des pièces voilà
vous avez trouvé
bien sûr cela touré fin qui n'a rien à
faire en effet maintenant le plus dur
est protégé par le fouet 3 il faut
trouver une bonne case à la hausse et
que l'on l'acthib le mieux
je pense que vous avez trouvé à l'oeil
ça se voit tout de suite voyez donc là
y'a rien à faire de n'y a pas de
tactique il ya pas de là quelle pièce ne
joue pas à la tour eiffe info l'activer
pour la toucher a touché un oeil sur la
colonne jay on peut venir angers 4 ou
angers 5
pour activer cette tour très beau coup
les noirs jouent maintenant un excellent
coup est aussi d'amener cette beaucoup
ce coup là encore un coup simple je
m'enlève du cloud âge
plus il ya plus le clouage sur la sur le
fou je me mets sur place blanche on dit
souvent que quand on a lu un fou d'une
couleur ici cases noires la dame est
bien sûr le case blanche puisqu'elle
remplace le fou qui n'existe plus le fou
des cases blanches voilà donc elle prend
la couleur des cases de diagonale
inverser cette dame à deux idées ici
fait trois idées non un jeu sort du
clonage 2 je peux venir h3 avec petite
pression notez que la tour peut pas
venir attaquer ya le cavalier donc là
d'amour h3 ça peut ça peut être pénible
mais aussi attention la case b5
je peux venir en b 5 jeux doubles
potentiellement tour et dames ce qu'ils
attaquent transparence le fou là il
suffirait d'enlever ce fou encore une
fois et ça attaque la tour donc ça gagne
un temps sur la tour est derrière si je
bouge se fout par exemple prenant des 4
pourrait envisager de dalé gober le pion
le four b3 à la fin et j'ai gagné un
pion une position avantageuse d'une
finale mieux puisque ma structure de
pions et bien mieux que celle des noirs
des blancs mais je peux aussi venir en
f3 avec l'idée fous ces sept et je me
laisse matt pas facile à défendre ça
pose des problèmes
alors les blancs jouent donc un très bon
coup à noter aussi un que maintenant une
fois qu'on a joué 17 ya encore une idée
un secoué pendant un super mais il fait
tout à la fois on attaque des quatre
aussi attention et oui des quatre
attaques et défendu deux fois et attaqué
trois fois et donc secoué multiples un
superbe vraiment très très bon coup donc
là les blancs jouent un très bon coup si
magnifique tour g4 voilà donc g4 la
pièce qui ne jouait pas en effet
regardez maintenant de vie active elle
est à la fois défensives ici un petit
oeil sur g7 peut venir en h4 pour
empêcher et
fait pour attaquer h5 et pourquoi pas
jeter derrière et en plus en menant g4g
empêche l'idée d'un match trois coups
multiples aussi regarder aussi comme les
pions doublette encore les bouges pas
protège beaucoup de cases voilà ils
permettent quand même d'avoir des points
d'appui pour ses propres pièces et
empêcher l'ennemi de d'envahir son camp
c'est des pions qui parfois aussi donc
on rend le défensif et de soutien qui
est qui non négligeable câble et f6
maintenant le cabinet a fini son office
rien à faire puisqu'on pouvait pas venir
donc il revient vers le centre en
dessins qu'ils attaquent la tour très
bon et blanc jouent un très très bon
coup aussi tour h théâtre on reste à la
fois en défense et qui tu attaques sur
h7 ça mange pas de pain tour active un
problème dans be 5 c'était enfin oui
comme toutes les menaces étaient on
pouvait pas venir h3 on pouvait pas on
pouvais plus attaquer des cas puisque la
tour est venu en défense et bien y
rester là la quatrième idée après le
décloisonnement
c'était bien sûr en bessengue attaque la
tour et attention attention batterie
contre le foot est 3 doigts et voilà on
peut se poser la question qu'est ce qui
se passe si les noirs jouent le coup un
fou on prend des 4 on peut regarder des
quatre avec l'idée attention j'attaque
b3 oui donc là les blancs pour jouer
simplement tour prend des 4 gagnent une
pièce pour l'instant on pourrait on peut
pas se venger tout de suite sur b3 parce
qu'il aurait prise ici donc il faudrait
d'abord prendre en d4 est là simplement
les blancs prendrait du fou et après dun
prend b3 ici
ce serait une faute puisque là
simplement les blancs reprendre
reprendre et de la dame et après tout
reprend et simplement tour à 8
et c'est le fameux match du couloir
voilà vous voyez qu'elle a fait ça
marche pas donc attention méfiez vous
calculez vos variantes comme il faut
après tours à 1
ici les blancs reviennent là et les
noirs ne peuvent pas prendre en d4 pour
attaquer le four b3 à cause du mas du
couloir mais attention les noirs jouent
g6 l'a peut-être c'est maintenant on
peut re pourrait le faire faut calculer
faut regarder si c'est jouable
je n'ai pas dit que cela les salles
étaient quand même mais attention pour
il ya plus de 20 du couloir
donc il faut envisager un défaut prend
des quatre c'est possible donc il faut
faire attention avec les blancs et là
les blancs choisi son coup très solide
tomber un bon voilà au moins en tout cas
la question se pose plus on joue à tour
en b1 vis-à-vis tour d'aman menace
attention fou prend avec cet échec au
roi et la tour gan la dame et en même
temps on a éliminé tout tout un coup
facile à jouer qui peut pas être mauvais
donc c'est facile à trouver et c'est bon
c'est au nord de jouer il faut faire
quelque chose contre fou province est
donc les noirs sont obligés de revenir
ailleurs et donc ils enlèvent la dame en
17' tranquillou et on a enlevé la tour
d'une case active et en b aller active
aussi parce qu'elle est sur un kobe bon
ok mais moins qu'un racisme il est
étonnant quand on aura donc là les
blancs jouent dans détroit où je
centralise un peu la dame ont une petite
feuille sur la case b5 la casa 6
bon j'ai aussi un oeil sur la casse ces
quatre géants vide peut-être de jouer
poussé quatre camps padam b3 pour viser
la tension f7 aussi ou d'hommes s'éclate
pour viser 7 il ya d'armes ici on ice
est bon alors très dangereux qu'elle ait
des 5 voilà donc la c1 continuent
d'essayer d'améliorer la position de ces
pièces le cavaliere ici se faisait par
an rien pour l'instant
ils étaient dominés par le ps trois là
ils pouvaient pas venir ni ans et 4 ni
angers cas donc il essaie de ces petits
vais ailleurs il vient en d5
bon c'est pas mauvais il peut s'échanger
contre le fou 3 mais dans ce cas là il
permettrait aux lois aux blancs de
réunir leurs pions puis on prend et dans
ce cas là est la structure y ait tout de
suite de vie harmonieuse donc c'est pas
l'idée des noirs ils veulent
certainement pas prendre ce fou il me
laissait les pions et bien sûr isolé
mais en dessin qui bloque si le
diagonale du fou p3c c'est un bon coup
il peut venir en b 4 attaqué la dame
il peut aussi pourquoi pas se recycler
via e set elle a calé en sets pour venir
à 25 f cell protégé par le pion g6
attaque la tourache 4 et lui pose un
petit problème et en même temps ça
attaquerait en rêve 5
le club des quatre voilà donc c'est
peut-être un long chemin que veulent
faire les noirs desseins e7 f5 et c'est
évident on vise des quatre donc ici les
blancs tour g1
c'est pas mauvais attention quand même
ça enlève un défenseur au fou mais bon
il est protégé par la table donc lydie
dam des trois c'était peut-être aussi
voilà de libérer le passage de cette
tour regardez en masse les pions contre
le roi attention les tours les pièces
pendant les tours contre le roi les
pièces eux visent le roi le fouet sur
une diagonale date à gond des cinq blocs
son action et c'est bien protégé est bon
il est là faut faire attention beaucoup
comme tour g5 et on a un problème ici
qu'est ce qu'on fait faut bouger si on
bouge belle ce fou devient
potentiellement dangereux faire
attention poussée 7
alors on l'avait dit un peu tout à
l'heure aussi où c'est certes un petit
oeil sur age 2 en même temps je contrôle
des cases centrale ici bon ok je
contrôle à casey 4 aussi ça peut être
une idée plus tard et en même temps
surtout ben voila je libère l'action de
la tour sur le four b3 donc la dame peut
pas faire ce qu'elle veut il ya une
fouquet est fou qui en prit très
beaucoup des blancs maintenant quand une
fois fou j'ai cinq classiques ont bien
peu perturbé la tour des huit si les
noirs jouent et si son rêve que de ça
puisse tout ça affaiblit sa cloud est le
cas les des cinq ça affaiblit la grande
diagonale contre le roi ça fait de lui
le roi
si vous bougez vos pions trop hein ça va
deux ça commence à être pénible puisque
voilà le roi devient un petit peu ici
sujet est sujet aux courants d'air
alors si cette tour bouge bien le cas
vallée des saints qui est moins stable
c'est ça l'idée de fouler 5 aussi la
tour est obligé de bouger et ce cavalier
devient attaquable avec le fou et donc
il va être obligé de bouger et de
libérer de nouveau cette grande
diagonale de 8
voilà il est noir le fond tout de suite
très simplement par le ku'damm ces
quatre ans là attention attention
bathory la pouf là le câble est attaqué
on peux pas le défendre facilement il
faut bouger faire bouger
ou alors je vous le coup plus tendue que
joue car c'est ni si regardez seul autre
coup à part de bouger c'est tombé 5
c'est tendu ça paraît un peu délicat la
tour b 5 protège mais la tour et
potentiellement qu'est ce qui se passe
sur roubaix 5 sur x 4
tous âges
c'est ce qu'a joué car scène c'est là
qu'il faut voir son idée je vous laisse
en trente secondes c'est quand même
temps dieu comme défense un voire les
nerfs solides
alors qu'arsène aurait joué très
certainement regarder le coût d'un
médecin qui voit la contre attaque en
2005 l'idée c'est que on a un match
regardez si fou prend - kazim at sea fou
prend b5 le regarder simplement fait
dames prendront un chèque et là regardez
tout un pouf
c'est quasiment en fait sont donnés la
dame dont j'ai donné la dame avec avec
un quasi matt est un gros avantage pour
pour les noirs donc tombé 5 x 4 est
possible quand même on regarde fou à 80
ce cas là donc 2005
et là il faudrait que les blancs jouent
un coup passif
alors quoi d'autre attention f3 est
attaqué c'est simple on surveille avec
le fou mais du coup un peu un coup
d'épée dans l'eau
si on revient avec la dame s'est pas
l'air bon donc le seul autre coup c'est
fou d1 admettons food et 1 vous voyez
tout de suite donc ça on comprend tout
de suite que après fou d un le convoi 4
a pas réussi maintenant il suffit de
protéger cette tour on peut venir en b1
puis on crée d ancrer encore des
problèmes on as tout reprend fou tout
reprendre en prime trois échecs
on peut même venir en b2 faire pression
sur les deux bref c'est une catastrophe
donc tombé 5 en fait c'est un piège
vas-y joual joue au x 4 boom dame f5
donc là car il qu'ils ne tombent pas
dans le piège sous le joli coup j'aime
bien ce coup dams et 2
j'aime bien mc2 parce que il veut très
certainement créer une batterie l'a
toujours sur cette diagonale mais en
mettant la dame par exemple à 2 voilà
attaque le cavalier on peut aussi jouer
fous ces quatre ici à noter donc on va
on va s'aimer c'est pas très bon général
m la dame devant il vaut mieux se sent
la pisse mineurs soient devant et la
dame derrière
bon c'est une pièce à longue portée la
dame qui a aussi contrôler les colonnes
du monde elle est mieux placé en arrière
que que devant souvent on préfère
sacrifier si on sacrifie des piéces
mineurs pour que des pièces monde donc
il replace un peu ses pièces sur 7 sur
cette diagonale ici donc dame ces deux
s'est passé pas très mauvais fait c'est
même bon donc ici tout à huit voies la
toile et déjà on peut pas jouer damas
deux voilà c'est un premier point mais
bon c'est pas très grave
c'est pas trop forcer mon idée voilà fou
c4 il replace et d'attention la tour où
va la tour donc voilà il restera scène
pour garder un oeil sur le cavalier et
en même temps il a doublé les tours donc
il peut venir échanger une tour ici car
celle-ci l'ennui et les blancs attention
au final il s'est structuré mauvaise
alors il en plus en plus un ça compense
un peu mais c'est quand même
position que qui semble défensive un
thème structurelles c'est défensif
replace leur pièce maintenant ils
essaient désorganiser les pièces non
avant la liste noire du mal à trouver
leurs pieds et leurs cases optimale food
et 2 qui revient ici en d2 pourquoi mais
il libère l'action de la tour sur la
colonne il ne rien on peut envisager
pourquoi pas des sacrifices surtout si
le calice autun parce que évidemment le
purifient cette souris cloué ya que le
plus raciste qui défend donc attention
parce que tout reprend puis on peut
imaginer que lecavalier n'est pas
l'arbre on fait tout reprend puis on
prend d'un prend carrément puisque le
turf 7 et cloud et oui qu'il faut garder
le pied le carillon de 2,5 c'est pour ça
qu'on essaie de tenir au maximum avec
les noirs ici donc vous des douves à la
tour et on enlève un défenseur de la
cause de la casse des cinq on veut
libérer cette diagonale avec les blancs
c'est clair les noirs jouent toi qu'as
tu penses au coût très important parce
que si on avait joué ici un coup comme
tour je peux aller à cette coupe a thief
l'admettons regarder un coup très fort
ici
ces dames 4 boum
comment protège ça parce que s'il sort
regarder imaginer qu'ils sortent donc en
relayant jesse savez vous montre un peu
l'idée quand même quel g6 calm air
breizh attaque le fou et non regardez
boom il faut le voir ça boume voilà
regarder pourquoi parce qu'il ya le f77
qui défendent fct et cloud et voilà on a
on a explosé le boucharlat c'est un
bouffeur de diagonale le cahier des cinq
donc la ccm à tania matmat force et puis
on prend il faut que l'on regarde
impossible dimpre en échec ou valleroy
n'y a pas le choix un g8 en fuite pardon
et là on donne le choix on peut jouer
fou b4 si on veut mais c'est même pas la
peine tout rage suite échec croît de 7
tout simplement
et maintenant tout est bon jeu
dans un premier set où il ya plus court
me fais mais d'abord fou des quatre
échecs on est sa bouche la casse des six
donc les noirs sont obligés de jouer par
mme d'anne decis ou food et 6 admettons
food et 6,5 alors on va donner la dame
et bien simplement maintenant d'armes
preuve cet essai maths parce qu'on a
beau bloquer la casse 10,6 en faisant un
échec ici on a obligé le noir de mettre
une pièce fait surtout on a contrôlé la
caisse des six mois la mélasse et mat
voyez donc c'est un gros match donc
attention food et 2 l'idée c'est ça
c'est qu'on veut jouer dans mon coeur
on enlève la tour de la défense de d5
aidé à me 4 avec quatre essais finit
donc on peut pas jouer n'importe quoi
avec les noirs ici d'où l'idée tour à
quatre voix la droite 4 je peux pas
jouer dans le 4 puis ce qui aurait tout
reprend fou tout simplement
et voyez ça tient à la ddt au dynamisme
la satire n'y a pas de problème il faut
faire attention
là les blancs jouent un conte curieux
dam des trois qui nous sommes pas très
bon presque l'impression d'avoir un peu
d'attentes un autre 36e coup il ya
peut-être un point de tandem des trois
salles s l'attention d'imposition ça
paraît pas super super fort un bon jeu
pendant qu'une dame b 3 avait l'air
quand même plus plus tendu mais les
noirs auraient pu attaquer la dame
peut-être je ne sais pas les noirs
maintenant choisissent d'aller échanger
des tours voilà toit est aussi un bon
coup puisque maintenant en k2 dames 4
bien la tour g1 cloud et voilà sur dame
e4 je te soit vous jouez jouez cavaillé
sont d'abord échangé la tour il ya plus
de sacrifices angers 6 puisque c'est
tourner ne peut pas sortir de la
première rangée tu auras un des blancs
pourpre en échec et roger de volaille
mais le roi ce que sur la deuxième
les nord a échangé une paire de tours du
coup la pression s'est allégée sur le
sur le roi noir la paire de fou fou
quand même appelait on voit bien que
c'est fou son son puissant on a vu comme
le fou de cases noires avaient perturbé
la tour des huit perturber la torah 5 et
que le foot case blanche lui attend que
ça que ce cavalli saute l'un pour avoir
son action sur cette diagonale
au maximum et on voit bien qu'il est
pénible se font donc là les noirs jouent
un coup intéressant car les recettes
caillou 7
on avait parlé un peu tout à l'heure
cette idée cavalli et 6 km et 5
une possibilité qui était d'activer ce
cavalier en revenant à f/5 salaires ça a
l'air bon et en fait une faute
là c'est une faute et l'a incarné qui
n'auraient pu prendre l'aventage il va
prendre fin il va prendre un petit
avantage mais il aurait pu avoir un gros
avantage ou pense ici qui l'a pas vu
donc il faut absolument qu'on voit c'est
une faute on a libéré cette fameuse démo
dalle regardez maintenant on peut jouer
le simple dames b3 boom batterie attaqué
cette que font les noirs à l'oreille un
piège
imaginez maintenant que les alors pour
protéger vii le seul coup qui semble
jouable mais ça peut pas le seul coup de
toute façon sinon avec cette bande son
mais admettons cavaliers f5 les
meilleures défenses regardez l'idée on
joue quand même fou prend effet cet
échec
d'accord là on a gagné un pion on
pourrait encore jouer trois g7 avec
l'idée ben j'ai quand même j'attaque la
tour il faudrait quand même joué comme
ça change rien parce qu'on vous tour h3
et la position est la même donc il faut
prendre on va prendre un excellent pour
justifier pour voir la justification du
sacrifice parce que là on a sacrifié
quand même regarder simplement on
reprend échec reprend d'accord et
maintenant regarder tout simplement tout
reproche 7 et le roi est attaqué et le
fou et si le cavaliere revient il ya
simplement fou h6 récupère la pièce avec
cette fois deux pions de plus c'est pas
du tout pareil les noirs n'ont plus
qu'un pion la finale est un véritable
avantage des blancs très nettement très
nettement
donc c'est une faute en fait sur moi
j'ai deux cavaliers 7 qui semble bon
pour venir ici une faute que carey qui
n'auraient pu profiter d'un automne dont
carey qui ne plie profiter par dans b3
et leur bizarrement il rentre dans une
autre variante qui est pas mauvaise non
plus c'est pas mauvais je vais pas dire
que c'est mauvais mais c'est autre chose
c'est une tante qui est moins puissante
malgré qu'elle semble plus plus
agressive
il joue le direct foot à vii passé pas
mal d'ailleurs c'est mauvais mais c'est
moins fort
c'est moins fort que ce qu'on vient de
voir après cette fois roy prend f7 mais
c'est un peu la même idée au sens où
voilà bah je vais pouvoir prendre h7
avec échec quand je veux là mais avant
khanaqinne
plutôt que de faire ça joue le simple
regard des dames ces quatre échecs
pas mal alors si les noirs avaient
défendu par d'amd 5 et bien le fou c7
est en prise s'il avait défendu ici par
cavale et des 5
et bien tout reproche cette gaine la
dame qu'il reste un seul coup qui semble
bon serwa g7
attention il est blanc quand même donné
une pièce il faut faire attention voilà
c'est la partie et la carac in jouant un
bon coup mais qui est moins puissant que
ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure ils jouent
des simples pourquoi c'est moins
puissant que ce qu'on a vu d'abord ici
on voit bien qu'on bouche la colonne bon
on libère attention on libère la grande
diagonale ici on menace un échec c'est
ça l'idée un échec ici à des prises de
la tour mais ce pion dessin qui en prise
alors que dahmane tout à l'heure il
n'était pas en prison entré dans la
finale avait de gros pions de plus donc
c'est pas tout à fait pareil et surtout
que là le noir ne craque pas et ils
jouent un rôle intéressant et très bon
ici alors ils auraient pu même jouer
d'autres coups ici et ils jouent le coup
kb les f-5 peut pas avoir tous les coups
mais c'est un bon coup en fait je contre
attaque sur la tour et je place enfin
mon cavalier en défense on contrôle un
petit peu les cases noires autour du roi
comme une pièce de plus ici tout de
suite donc si les blancs prennent la
tour ici je me venge sur l'autre je
connais je reste avec une pièce de plus
attention mais aussi la dame ici
attention comment ce contrôle aussi des
lacets cette septième rangée
donc c'est un coup défensif qui réactive
les pièces donc la carte qui n'a pas
joué la bonne variante pour garder un
avantage ici il aurait pu sans doute
être plus précis avec l'automne en fait
c'est pas ça reste bon pour les blancs
après fou ces trois échecs quand même
regarder wife 8
simplement on prend la toile on est
toujours dans la tactique ici qu à l epr
en h4 échec et simplement on reprend de
la dame voilà on prend la dame donc on a
récupéré la pièce donc ce qu'a joué car
ce n est une bonne défense on a échangé
finalement les tous mais à la fin d'en
prendre 5
ça fait une grosse différence vous voyez
avec la redoute tout à l'heure où je
gardais ce pion dans b3 et est donc plus
fort
ça reste quand même bien pour les blancs
ils ont un pion de plus mais c'est des
pions quand même pareil doublé des pions
isolés on peut pas considérer que c'est
un vrai pion de plus la position rendant
une finale assez égal voire même
totalement égal on peut pas vraiment
aidé à taxer très fier monter les
attaques aussi avec des fous de même
couleur
donc même s'ils restent les dames la
position des rois n'est pas n'est pas
vraiment danger avec les fous de même
couleur
il suffit qu'un fou contrôler les en
défense ça va c'est bien pour la défense
donc c'est pas un gros gros soucis il
faut juste faire attention
la mef six échecs dames excède pas de
problème la finale est nul
1 pourquoi parce que je mets avec le roi
je vais mettre le roi sûr aussi c'est si
je peux même sur f cell mais même si ce
et les pions sur blanc on peut pas en
plus jamais avancer quoi voilà on peut
jamais avancer la cause des saints qui
est protégé
avec le roi est donc bon et puis à la
fin imaginer qu on enlève deux pions de
chaque côté dans le meilleur des cas il
suffit que de mettre le roi sur cases
blanches on bouge plus devant le pian et
après on fait que bouger le fou et c'est
nul
donc c'est facile à annuler ça en fait
des pions sur du même côté il n'y a pas
de plan pas 7e qui ont passé c'est pas
tout à fait la même mais voilà ici la
non-élection doublé de même côté rien à
faire dam des quatre dons qui jouent
encore quelques coups à 8 dans le quatre
échecs dames cette dame dessin il essaye
un brand pas grand-chose food et 8
bref ça être un peu ennuyé la suite un
souvenir d'un f7 fameux 4 échecs dames
cette fois aux symboles aussi il joue
peut-être la fatigue aussi un quart à
kinmen d'un point il a vu car c'est
quand même fait une faiblesse à la prépa
la précédente
on est à la 9e aussi donc il va ya voir
le jour de repos dont qui le fatigue au
maximum bon il risquera rien avec les
blancs mais bon car chaînes non plus je
pense qu'il n'avait pas de problème ici
surtout qui calme très vite et je pense
qu'il ya pas de soucis de six mois j'ai
deux sets pour les faire un ami 8 échecs
si on pousse les pions on peut pas avec
les blancs pour rien faire avec ça
qu'est ce que voulait créer des menaces
avec des pions aussi aussi
catastrophique c'est les noirs qui ont
un petit avantage de structure mais
comme une option de moins ça joue pas
non plus
bref cette dame je suis tâte encore
attention le peuple ossète et attaquez
vous parler de menaces ici c'est pas
très grand mais voilà on joue h5 d'alger
cet échec vite
katia rien rien du tout la mef cette
dame a suite on a vu des fuites dans des
quatre voilà on continue à s'amuser
il y à que dalle il n'y a rien du tout
17 food et 2 2 me 6 voilà on regarde et
on propose même échange je voulais dit
si on met l'euro à 1 6 comment voulez
vous passer pouvait rien faire sur les
cases noires vous jamais avancé le roi
puis même si vous pouviez vous pouvez
jamais avec l'orangé 5 il ya le fouille
qui empêche si on attaque avec le fou on
enlève et puis dès qu'on enlève le fonds
en euros mais voilà on peut rien faire
on peut pas passer c'est facile de le
comprendre la case f5 empêche toute
rupture
rien à faire là mais cheikh s'est si
souvent la dame à cette dame c'est sept
mois je suis prêt à changer d'âme pas de
problèmes dans ma deux dames les six
mois car akin essaye de passer mais ya
rien à faire
faux et trois lames cissé bonne guerre
mais bon là cet échec 8 pouces et 5 à
propose des changes les fous elle
préfère les garder c'est plus facile
d'annuler avec les fous h3 d'amd 5-fu 3
me suis senti tenu le même un échange de
fous je crois pas une seconde de cette
finale la fossette d'amd vite d'avedro
f7 d'un mach 8,26 faut être quatre 2006
d'un bep 8 lames 617 roi g8 dans b5 et
enfin voila apres fou et 6 les deux
camps s'accordent pour faire nul alors
c'est nul sans doute dès le début voilà
donc une belle nul de combat mais mais
mais peut-être encore une fois et ça ça
fait un peu peur pour le camp car scène
je pense encore une fois donc les
semblerait la cocaïne est raté encore
une fois une petite faute de carre scène
je vous rappelle la position c'était au
38e coup approché d'eux car ils cèdent
permettait un coup qui a l'air très fort
ici qui est donc le fameux table b 3 que
font les noirs ici pas évident évident
sur le coup donc standard 1 le couple
est prévu car c'est ni si un tristement
qu'un bon coup qu'un des meilleurs coups
et si ce n'est le meilleur ici de jouer
quand même 4e 5 c'est pas la même
regardez on peut analyser il faut
analyser ça vous prélève cet improbable
s'est efforcé quasiment c'est même sur
ses forces et attention le cavalier
aussi la tour dite attaquer mais bon
c'est pas grave en province est
simplement dans prend on va prend tout
reproche 7
échec et peut-être dans ce cas là il
rejoue à peut-être joué gros 1,6 alors
quand même ici
ce soit l'un soit ressorti peut-être
comme ça sur eux aussi s'ils auraient
laissé en fait la prise du fou pour
effectivement dans ce cas là alors est
ce qu'il aurait pu prendre en d4
ah oui ils pouvaient aussi faire une
nuit la vida qu il pouvait faire nul
avec cavaliers aussi peut-être un
cafouillage quatre échecs
est ce que fait le roi si le roi vit à
angers 3 on revient à angers quatre
échecs au f4 parce que là ça laisse les
pions un peu isolés ici on prend des 4
et puis peut-être avec la tour on va
harceler le pion h 2 on va harceler
aussi le pion f3 on peut aussi jouer
tour à 3 pour attaquer f3 on peut aussi
jouer des échecs ici un ici qu'a lieu de
chèques 4 pouces et 3 je viens de
chèques suite on a deux sur le truc mais
ça doit pas être mauvais pour les noirs
ça en plus il ya des couleurs opposées
je sais même pas si le carrier pas plus
à l'aise ici que le fou est finalement
oui ça doit être ça doit suffire quand
même pour annuler mais bon on regarde et
il ya quand même deux pions de moins
voilà mais bon c'est vrai que si c'est
des pions doublé alors à noter que la
imaginons qu'on élimine un pion contre
neutre et puis avec les pions doublé on
va sans doute arriver à devoir en
prendre un autre
on va arriver à prendre deux pions je
pense ici et les blancs reste ravi comme
si on passait bon pourquoi pas
eh bien le cavalier pour sacrifier
contre ce pion et la fameuse finale
touré fou contre tours à noter que ça
peut gagner dans certains cas mais
m'élancer nul si on connaît bien la
défense on a vu qu arsène gagné déjà
cette finale en finale de faim lors du
championnat du monde de blitz contre ce
vide l'air vous avez la partie sur
internet vous invite à la voir car scène
vide l'air finale deux tours
je sais plus quelle année mais c'était
assez fabuleux de voir comment il a
réussi à gagner à transformer une finale
en finale touristes contre tous tout ça
pour dire que son appareil de rui lopez
rue lopez déjà disait que la finale
touré fou contre tours donc en cas où le
cavalier devrait se sacrifier contre les
contrôles et pions dans le contre tours
étaient souvent on pouvait il a gagné
voilà que c'était très difficile à
défendre
mais que non blancs sur une bonne
défense ça pouvait faire nul et philidor
lui-même avait montré les cas la fameuse
position de fines et de philidor de
tours est fou contre tours ou donc on
pouvait forcer le gain il faut que le
roi soit à la bande dans une position
particulière et la technique et est
délicate voilà les deux grands anciens
c'est pour ça que c'est important de
d'étudier aussi les grands anciens à
cause de ces subtilités la voilà donc ce
qu'il aurait pu faire mais quand même
avec une finale à l'avantagé des blancs
ici où l'on aurait pu travailler
beaucoup mieux que dans la finale qu'on
a vu voilà on peut-être carsen pouvait
encore tenir
donc il était quand on est sous pression
car yakine donc sort de cette neuvième
partie avec un gros avantage à la fois
au point et psychologique puisqu'il a
mené ce jeu-là il a quand même été
en attaque car c'est là encore fait une
micro une au micro faute qui aurait pu
lui causer des soucis à la paire de fois
réussi à jouer du côté blanc mat chypre
est extrêmement tendue un point d'avancé
pour caler à qui il reste maintenant
après donc cette neuvième partie reste
trois parties donc deux fois les blancs
pour qu'arsène pour revenir au score est
ce qu'il va être obligé de jouer tout
sur la dernière partie la 12e comme un
petit peu kasparov et karpov 1987 à
séville on verra ça il ya déjà la
prochaine partie qui risque d'être
explosive
que va faire car c'est ni va sans doute
jeté toutes ses forces dans la bataille
pour essayer de revenir et ne pas
laisser car yakine de ravir ce titre
extrêmement précieux de champion du
monde d'échecs voilà merci d'avoir suivi
sur des modèles tv pour cette
fantastique parti à 9e superbe donc de
sergueï kaliakine face à magnus carsen
match nul dans cette partie mais car à
kinmen toujours d'un point à trois
parties de la fin au revoir à bientôt
pour la prochaine de ce superbe
championnat du monde 2016 sur des gones
ltv au revoir